so let's give ourselves an overview of
glycolysis and glycolysis is an
incredibly important biochemical pathway
it occurs in in practically all life as
we know it and it's all about taking
glucose as a fuel and in the process of
breaking it up lysing the glucose
glycolysis breaking it up into two
pyruvate
two pyruvate molecules glucose is a six
carbon molecule each of the pyruvates
are three common three carbon molecules
in the process of doing that you produce
two atp's net it actually turns out that
you need to use two atps and then you
produce four so you use
you use two atps that's often called the
investment phase and we'll talk about
that in a second and then you produce
you produce
four atps
for a net
for a net of plus two
atps and that's what we see right over
here you see a a net of two atps being
produced directly by glycolysis and then
you also have you also have the
reduction of nad to nadh remember
reduction is all about gaining electrons
and over here nad that's nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide we have other
videos on that it's a it's an
interesting molecule it's actually a
fairly a decent sized molecule
we see this positive charge but then we
see that not only does it gain a
hydrogen but it loses its positive
charge so it gains a hydrogen and an
electron you could think on a net basis
it's gaining a hydride it's gaining a
hydride now a hydride anion is not going
to typically be all by itself but on a
net basis you can think about that's
what's happening
and so it's gaining a hydrogen and an
extra electron and so this the nad plus
this is going to get reduced
that is going to get reduced to nadh
so this is getting reduced to nadh and
that nadh once it's
it can then be oxidized in the electron
transport chain and we'll study that
later on when we think about oxidative
phosphorylation to produce even more
atps but
on a very high level simple basis
glucose being broken down in pyruvate
six carbons three carbons each of these
pyruvates now there's other things
attached to the carbon so we'll see that
in a little bit
two atps net generated
and you have the reduction of nad two
nads to two nadhs and those can be used
later on to produce more atps now
glycolysis is typically just the
beginning of cellular respiration if
oxygen is around then you have these
products some of these products moving
into the mitochondria
where you can have the citric acid cycle
krebs cycle and the oxidative
phosphorylation occur if you don't have
oxygen around then you're going to do
anaerobic respiration or you're going to
go into fermentation we'll talk about
that in a future video and that's really
about figuring out what to do with these
products and especially replenishing
your nad plus
now now that we have a very high level
overview of like glycolysis let's get a
better appreciation for exactly what's
going on and whenever i look at these
more detailed
more detailed processes the one thing to
just appreciate is
is how much complexity is occurring in
in all of your cells right now this this
isn't some just well it is fairly
abstract you just even imagine these
things
but this is happening throughout your
body gazillions of times right now this
isn't something that's somehow distant
from you and it's also fun to appreciate
well how how all of this was discovered
by scientists that's a whole other
fascinating discussion but the whole
point of this video is just give us an
appreciation for the actual mechanism or
the or the reaction by which it occurs
i'm not going to go into the detailed
organic chemistry mechanism so over here
this is a glucose molecule over here you
see one two three four five six carbons
and then the first step is it gets
phosphorylated and we have a whole video
on the phosphorylation of glucose and
all of these steps are facilitated with
enzymes the phosphorylation is
facilitated with the hexokinase kinase
is a general term for an enzyme
that either facilitates phosphorylation
or dephosphorylate or d phosphorylates
it's it's dealing with phosphorylation i
guess you can say and all enzymes are
all about lowering the activation energy
and the way that hexokinases do or part
of how they do it is they involve the
cofactor magnesium ion and we've talked
about that in other videos how cofactors
can help an enzyme lower the activation
energy and to do the phosphorylation we
use an atp so this is -1
minus 1 atp so we are in the investment
phase we are in the investment phase
right over here but this reaction it
strongly goes from left to right it's a
coupled reaction that taking that
phosphorylating the glucose
that that requires free energy but the
atp releases free energy you couple
these reactions it strongly goes from
left to right
now what and just to be clear what
happened this
this over here got replaced or maybe i
should say this over here got replaced
with that
over there just to keep track of what's
happening
now another enzyme catalyzed reaction
this one is actually an equilibrium it
can go both ways but as we'll see the
right side or or the the things that are
further into the glycolysis process
these are constantly being turned into
further products so their concentrations
are going to go down so the reaction is
will tend to go that way although this
this particular reaction going from
glucose 6-phosphate to fructose
6-phosphate this could be an equilibrium
but the enzyme that facilitates this
phosphoglucose isomer isomerase
isomerases these are enzymes that help
grow from one isomer of a molecule to
another isomer and that's what's
happening here instead of this oxygen
being bound to this carbon this bond
forms with this carbon and so you have
fructose you have the five carbon ring
over here or you have the five element
ring you have four carbons in it versus
a six element ring where right over here
you have five carbons so this bond goes
to this carbon right over here and
that's the main difference
and then you have another very strong
forward reaction once again facilitated
by atp and this is done by
phosphofructokinase it has the word
kinase in it and it's using up the atp
you can guess what's going to happen
we're going to attach another phosphate
group
to the
fructose-6-phosphate and now you have
two of these phosphate groups so
so this this hydrogen right over here is
now replaced with another
with another phosphate group and once
again it's facilitated by the magnesium
cofactor it helps stabilize some of the
negative charge associated with the
phosphate groups we talk about that in
other videos but the important thing is
it uses another atp we're still in the
investment phase negative one
negative one atp and every time i look
it's just fascinating that all of this
stuff is happening in your cells as we
speak in fact in order for me to speak
this has to happen because my body needs
to take glucose and come up with some
energy to turn to atps so that my
muscles can actually move and i can
actually inhale and exhale and all the
things that i need to do for speech so
appreciate what's going on over here
now the next step we talk about the
whole process the whole process of
glycolysis is lysing glucose and over
here this is this is derived from
glucose and some phosphate and the next
step we're actually going to break it up
and we're going to break it up using the
enzyme fructose biphosphate aldolase
aldolase enzymes they facilitate the
aldol reaction this in this one we're
going to actually the aldol reaction
could be to
merge two to put together two molecules
or in this case we're going to break
them up and we break them up into two
three carbon chains now these two three
carbon chains glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and this character right over here they
can be converted between the two with
another isomerase this triose phosphate
isomerase right over here so at this
point in glycolysis we can think of
ourselves as really having two of these
so let's say two times glyceraldehyde
three phosphate so as we go further on
just imagining this happening twice for
every glucose molecule
and anytime you get confused i encourage
you to pause the video and see how these
pieces and these pieces put together can
form that over there
so now we have another reaction it's
facilitated by a dehyd dehydrogenase
dehydrogenases usually are are involved
in this case this is this is this is the
reduction of nad we saw that in the
overview video so nad is being
is being reduced and this can be used
this nadh later on can be used in the
electron transport chain to potentially
produce some more atp but in that
process in that process we also add
another phosphate group to the
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate so you see
this phosphate group you see this
phosphate group right over here that
wasn't
that wasn't here that wasn't there
before
that wasn't there before and actually
this right over here is i should i
should
i should have arrows on both sides this
right over here that reaction could
actually go both directions actually
that reaction can as well
and then
and then
we we we are now going to be in the
payoff phase
so this right over here
we're starting with this molecule that
has these two phosphate groups and then
using the phosphoglycerate kinase we're
able to pop one of those phosphate
groups off and in the process produce
atp
produce atp now we might want to say
plus one atp but we have to remember
this is now happening twice because we
had two of those glyceraldehyde three
phosphates so now we could say if we're
talking about this happening twice two
plus two atps we are now in the payoff
phase
then you have facilitated by the
phosphoglycerate mutase a mutase is a
class of isomerases i have trouble
saying that that'll take a functional
group from one place to another or take
one part of a molecule to another part
and you see this phosphate group
you see this phosphate group moving on
from this carbon to the middle carbon
and so that's what that's doing then we
use an inolase to get over here and then
the pyruvate kinase the pyruvate kinase
and here the kinase is going to be used
to dephosphorylate this molecule right
over here and it gets us to the way i've
drawn it is pyruvic acid since i've
drawn i have the hydrogen here and if
the hydrogen is let go and this oxygen
hogs the electron we would call this
pyruvate and this is considered to be
the end of i guess you could say
mainstream glycolysis but what happened
and and and i don't want to glaze over
what happened over here this adp got
converted to another atp but it's going
to happen twice so this is another plus
two
atps so hopefully you see the investment
phase
we use an atp right over here to
phosphorylate the glucose we use another
atp right over here to throw that second
phosphate group on the what was this the
fructose 6-phosphate but then we get the
payoff phase so we're able to produce
this nadh and this is actually going to
be two nadhs because everything here is
going to happen twice now we can assume
that this character over here also gets
gets converted to a glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and now we produce two atps
because this is happening twice and we
produce two atps right over there so
hopefully everything we talked about in
the beginning of everything we talked
about in many actually makes sense